good evening and welcome to fox news
primetime i'm rachel campos-duffy and we
start tonight with joe biden's week from
hell the president hasn't had a week
like this since his disgraceful and
deadly retreat from kabul
he saw his entire agenda fall apart in
real time these past seven days and even
someone as out of it as sleepy joe has
to realize
things are getting bad on monday the u.s
shattered records with over 1.3 million
coveted cases in a single day
for the guy who promised america he
would shut down the virus it seems like
he's doing the exact opposite so biden's
week started off over one
on tuesday things only got worse for the
embattled president biden went down to
georgia to attack the filibuster
i believe the threat to our democracy is
so grave
that we must find a way to pass these
voting rights bill we have no option but
to change the senate rules including
getting rid of the filibuster for this
biden's speech caught flack from both
sides of the aisle as he trashed senate
rules and looked to smear any american
who cares about election integrity as a
racist
so if you're keeping score at home
that's 0 and 2 for biden this week and
if you thought things were getting
getting any better as the week moved on
think again on wednesday the labor
department announced the consumer price
index jumped seven percent in december
the worst since 1982. thanks to biden's
poor economic policies prices are the
highest they've been in 40 years now you
know how your wallet's been feeling a
little light lately well you can thank
joe biden for that
and the pain didn't stop there as the
release of a new poll highlighted
biden's fall from grace
his job performance rating hit a new low
with only 33 percent of americans saying
they approve of biden and more than 50
percent disapproving and that was only
wednesday which brings us here to
yesterday where it was a thursday to
forget for this administration kamala
harris didn't do her boss any favors
when she sat down for a one-on-one with
nbc
she got tripped up on what should have
been a pretty obvious question that
sounded like a beauty pageant contestant
who would have thrown a curveball in an
interview
at what point does the administration
say you know what this strategy isn't
working we're going to change strategies
is it time
it is time for us to
do what we have been doing and that time
is every day
every day it is time for us to agree
that
there are things and tools that are
available to us to slow this thing down
but this train wreck of an interview
buys second in command just continued
biden's no good terrible thursday joe's
vaccine mandate on private businesses
which would have affected more than 80
million americans was shot down by the
supreme court the nation's highest court
told biden that our personal freedoms
outweighed his executive overreach so as
thursday came to a close biden was
looking at an 0 for 4 week
and this morning there was no reprieve
as the pain continued for joe biden was
forced to admit that he hasn't done a
whole lot as president
a lot of talk about uh
disappointments and things we haven't
gotten done
we're going to get a lot of them done i
might add
that's pretty rich joe he admits he
hasn't done anything to help the people
who elected him but then slips into a ah
don't worry we'll get it done
unfortunately we don't believe you joe
and things are getting so bad for biden
that even his trusty leftist media has
turned on him
president joe biden has had a very tough
week with setbacks for his agenda every
time i think the white house thought
they've hit bottom there seems to be a
new bottom the overall sentiment not
just among the american public but even
among democrats in washington people who
are allies of this administration is
that this is a
really bad period for the biden
administration
the biden administration continues to
fail every step of the way and even the
left can't hide it anymore
so here's the important question what is
the white house going to do about it
well it doesn't look like they have a
plan at all if anything their
frustration is reaching critical levels
you do hard things in white houses
you have every challenge at your at your
feet laid out your feet whether it's
global or domestically and we could
certainly propose legislation to see if
people
support bunny rapids and ice cream but
that wouldn't be very rewarding to the
american people
bunny rabbits and ice cream that's what
the white house has come to well it's so
clear that they are in over their heads
they can't handle the crisis that
they're currently facing so what happens
when a new crisis arrives like the
mother of all supply chain problems that
is emerging right now in china we're
still feeling the pain from our current
supply chain crisis and another supply
bubble is ready to burst economists are
warning that if covet continues to
spread across asia the disruption to
manufacturing could be catastrophic as
we're too reliant on china to make the
things that we need
it's been a very bad week for joe biden
probably the worst seven days of his
presidency he saw america's institutions
and people reject everything he
campaigned on nearly one year after his
inauguration joe biden's presidency has
hit a breaking point hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else